مساء الخير السؤال القديم الجديد هل
تستطيع ايران تنفيذ تهديداتها باغلاق مضيق
هرمس ردا على العقوبات الامريكيه الهادفه
الى تصفيه صادراتها من النفط علشان نعرف
الاجابه على السؤال ده محتاجين نعرف
معلومات اساسيه عن مضيق هرمز الاول
واهميته وتاريخ ال مضيق هرمز اللي العالم
كله يسمع عنه هو مضيق بيروت ما بين الخليج
العربي وبحر العرب وخليل معنا واذا كنت
مهتمه او بالتفاصيل تقدر تقول باختصار
شديد جدا بيربط الخليج العربي
بالمحيط الهندي والبحر العربي وخليج او م
انهما جزءا اساسيا من
الخليج الهندي وبالتالي فهو حيوي جدا لنقل
كل صادرات منطقه الخليج سواء الدول
العربيه او ايران من الناحيه الاخرى الى
مختلف دول العالم هو بدايه
الدول الخليج يعني التقديرات وكاله
الوكاله ال معلومات الطاقه الامريكيه اللي
بتصدر تقارير دوريه عن حركه النفط في كل
مكان النفط والغاز يعني بتقول انه وفق
الارقام 2016 اللي ما اختلفت شي كثير عن
السنوات الابلاغ في ثمنطاشر ونصف مليون
برميل بطول بيعدوا عن طريق
كلهم يعني حوالي سته وسبعه من عشره مليار
برميل سنويا دول بيمثلوا اكثر من ذلك كميه
البترول اللي ب ينقلها البحر في مختلف دول
العالم و بتمثل حوالي خمس خمسه وثمانين في
المائه من انتاج دول الخليج وايران كذلك
بالاضافه طبعا الى كل غاز قطر على سبيل
المثال او معظم ال قطر على سبيل المثال
بالتالي اهميه مدريد للدول المصدره
والدور المستورده لا يمكن ابدا
فيه هو بالغ الاهميه للعالم كله
ملاقي المبالغ الاهميه للعالم كله فلا ما
هو مرتبط بعمليه التوتر والصراع
والتهديدات الكلام ده مش من النهار ده
الكلام ده من يعني مئات السنين لانه دائما
كان مضيق مهم جدا لكل الامبراطوريات
القديمه والحديثه
اذكركم انه
في اثناء حرب العراق وايران اللي كانت من
سنه الف وتسعمائه وثمانين الف وتسعمائه
وثمانيه وثمانين كما ينص في القلب من هذا
الصراع في السنوات الاخيره من الحرب كان
كان المضيق شهد ما عرف باسم حرب الناقلات
كان حرب النقل الهدى الهدف منه انه كل طرف
ايران والعراق بتحاول اغراق صادرات اغراق
الناقلات اللي تحمل صادرات الدوله الاخرى
اه الى العالم الخارجي وبالتالي الاضرار
باقتصادها لكن ما حاولوا ايران ظهرت
الصادرات المشكلات العراقيه والعراق
الصادرات الايرانيه لكن تضررت كل
الحاملات او كل ناقلات البترول لكل دول
العالم
واضطرت بعض دول العالم انها تجد وسائل
مختلفه للحيلوله دون الاصابه من النيران
القادمه من الجهتين
الكويت مثلا اضطرت لرفع العالم الامريكي
وفي النهايه اضطرت الولايات المتحده
للتدخل بنفسها علشان
ضبط ايقاع الخليج اللي هي بتقول الارقام
الامريكيه ان هي ال فقط عليه اكثر من 8
مليار دولار للابقاء عليه
يعني املا في اه الامن اللي الملاحه
البحريه وبعد انتهاء الحرب او في تحديدا
في ابريل الف وتسعمائه وثمانيه وثمانين
نتيجه انه فرقا امريكيه اصيبت باضرار
بالغه نتيجه اللغم
ايراني انفجر فيها قدام بالسواحل القطريه
قامت الولايات المتحده بعمليه عسكريه واخر
تقريبا نص الاسطول العامل الايراني نص
يعني قطع الاسطول الايراني في ايضا
الوقت في عمليه التوتر وطوال الوقت تقريبا
كل المناورات العسكريه اللي بتعملها ايران
هدفها واحد هدفها الرئيسي التاكد من
قدرتها على اغلاق المريض فيه عندما تحت
الى ذلك وكل النشاط العسكريه في او معظم
النشاط العسكري للولايات المتحده وحلفائها
الاوروبيين
وكذلك دول الخليج هدفها التاكد من عرقله
او قدره ايران على اغلاق المضيق في وقت
الملاحه البحريه وبالتالي البطوله
الاهتمام بالبترول مش بس الولايات المتحده
ودول الخليج لكم ان تتخيلوا طبعا معظم
البترول المنطقه بيروح الى دول شرق اسيا
يعني الصين واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
والهند الى اخره لكم ان تتخيلوا على سبيل
المثال انه اليابان خمسه وسبعين في المائه
من وارداتها بيمر حول بمر من دي من
المنطقه ويعبر مضيق هرمز الى اراضيها احنا
قدام السؤال اللي احنا طرحنا هي بتقدر
تغلق المضيق السؤال بالطريقه دي بياخذنا
الجوانب مختلفه يعني مثلا دائما في حاله
جدل ما بين العسكريين هي تقدر تغلقه ولا
بلاقي تقارير كثيره منشوره من ال مراكز
الابحاث العسكريه الامريكيه تشكك في
قدرتها على ان هي تقدر تغلق
الاسباب و بيتكلموا في اسباب فنيه انه
الناقلات الحديثه باعداء هيك المزدوج
وبالتالي من مشهد تكرر حرب الناقلات مره
ثانيه بان اي صاروخ يمكن ان يغرق المساله
تبقى صعبا ان اغراق او اعطاء ركلات السفن
التجاريه الحديثه مساله صعبه وب تكلموا
على امور الثانيه قدره الولايات المتحده
على التدخل بس التدخل دا معناه ايه التدخل
ده معناه انه هو يضرب الاسطول او يدرك
اهداف عسكريه ايرانيه اذا ضرب يبقى معناها
انه هو يساهم في اغلاق المضيق لانه ما فيش
تعدي اذا كانت في عمليه عسكريه الولايات
المتحده تضرب من الازمات ضرب من خارج
المنطقه عم تضرب من قواعدها اللي موجوده
في المنطقه في كل مكان خصوصا في دول
الخليج طب ليه ما تدخل شيء المضيق هو ده
نقطه ال ال
يعني ال ال او الاضافه او نقطه القوه لدى
الايرانيين
جغرافيا
ما فيه ما فيه تمثل تحدي كبير للولايات
المتحده وغيرهم ال مضيق هرمز ان تتخيل هو
طبعا المضيق يعني اي حد الله وعملت كذا
ابحاثها تطلع خريطه مضيق هرمس وبالمناسبه
هو اسمه يعني اه الى جزيره هو موجود
الجزيره قديمه جدا اليها تاريخ كبير لكن
ايا كانت مش موضوعنا الان يعني لكن ما
تشوف وما بيكر بس في الخا الخريطه
انه هو بيحدد الدول اللي تتحكم فيه ال
ايران من الشمال ومن الجنوب سلطنه عمان
نظريا المفروض كمان ان الامارات كانت
بتساهم فيه السيطره عليه من خلال الثلاث
كثر اللي هي ابوموسى وطنب الصغرى وطنب
الكبرى
لكن هذه الكثره التي كانت محل نزاع مع
الايرانيين استولى عليها الايرانيين
بالقوه منذ العام الف وتسع مائه وواحد
وسبعين وبالتالي قد ام احنا الطرفين
اساسيه ايران بشكل رئيسي في ال على حدودها
يعني من الشمال من كامل حدودها بالاضافه
الى الجزء اللي هي ال جزر الثلاثه
الاماراتيه التي استولت عليها الف
وتسعمائه وواحد وسبعين وفي الجنوب سلطنه
عمان الماضيه يبدو انه هو متسع على
الخريطه متسع يعني بيشوفوا انه في اضيق
نقطه بنتكلم على حوالي واحد وعشرين ميلا
يعني بتكلم في حدود اربعه وثلاثين كيلومتر
ويصل في اكبر اتساع لي ل 90 95 كيلو متر
مربع فبالتالي
كيلومتر وبالتالي ف احنا بنتكلم على مسافه
من الصغيره لكن عمليا ال ال ال المياه
عميقه في قناتين قناعه اه يعني قناتين في
اتجاهين عرض كل قناه اللي هو بيوصل اقصد
دفاع عليها في حدود اثنين يا اللي بتكلم
في حدود تقريبا ثلاثه كيلو اذا بنتكلم على
ثلاثه كيلو رايح و بالتاكيد نتكلم على
اتساع في حدود سته كيلو هي اللي اللي
السفن بتقدر التعدي فيها ثيابا وايابا
التضيق ال ال ال الضيق الشديد للخليج
المنطقه الصالحه لعبور ان الخلاف الضخمه
يمثل تحدي كان وما زال يمثل تحدي على ان
الولايات المتحده تستطيع ان هي نتواجد فيه
بصوره دائما في حاله وجود عداء دون ان
تتضرر مهما كان تفوقها العسكري
وعشان كده العسكريين بيتكلموا انه ال الم
في تفوق عسكري امريكي للولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في مواجهه حقيقيه يعني كبرت
الجغرافيا انه هو
ايران بالاضافه طبعا خبرات متراكمه عبر
عشرات السنوات
للاسطول والقوات المسلحه الايرانيه اللي
هي وصفه كل ادواتها وكل امكانياتها
للتعامل مع هذه البقره البقره الكافيه
الاستراتيجيه المهمه الدقيقه في كل
الاحوال
لانه انا لست وعسكريه يعني ما يقوله
العسكريون ان اخلاق المدينه لكن ايضا
حمايته من المضايقات الايرانيه ايضا وانه
الطريقه الوحيده اللي تستطيع الولايات
المتحده اللي عملت كده وتستطيع الان
ولاحقا انها هي تلحق اضرار بالغه جدا
الاسطول او القوات الايرانيه لكن اذا فعلت
ذلك فهي تزيد الطين بله لا مو معنى كده
انها تساعد في التوتر الموجود ان تؤدي الى
توقف الملاحه البحريه امام الناقلات
وبالتالي تتضرر الدول المستقبله للنفط
وبالتالي ترتفع اسعار النفط هو يتضرر
العالم كله الولايات المتحده واقول
الاقتصاديات المهمه وغير المهمه او الدول
الفقيره والدول الغنيه لكن احنا بنتكلم
كده على هذا هو الموقف بصفه عامه هل هي
ايران جاده في اغلاق المضيق اولا هي تواجه
عده مشاكل امام اغلاق المضيق
المشكله الاولى بغض النظر عن الامكانيات
العسكريه اللي تتغلب عليها بامكانيات
بسيطه بزرع الالغام والقوارب السريعه
القادره على اعطاء اه
سفر كبيره بعيدا عن النواحي العسكريه هي
وتواجه عده مشاكل المشكله الاولى انه
اغلاق المضيق
اولا اه يعني يعني مش بس غضب الولايات
المتحده ولا دول الخليج واضرابها ولكن
الاضرار ببعض من الحلفاء والدول المهمه في
العالم اللي هي ليست طرفا مباشرا في
الصراع الدائر في
الصين كوريا انما زي الهند وبالتالي هذه
الدول لم تسلط على توقف جزء كبير من
وارداتها من الطاقه
اثنين انه ايران نفسها قد تتضرر من اغلاق
المضيق لانه اولا هي صادرتها بتخرج كلها
من مضيق هرمس وبالتالي اذا هي علاقه الم
غير فهي كمان صادراتها لم تخرج اضف الى
كده انه ايران دوله مصدره لكنها ايضا
مستورده لبعض مشتقات البترول والغاز اللي
هي ما بتقدر شخصا معها وبالتالي تستوردها
ما يعني انه اخلاق المضيق هو الحقيقه كمان
يضرب نفسه بالرصاص في قدمها اللي نفسها
ممكن المساله ما في يعني لا يعني اغلاق
الماديه تتكلم دا السيناريو كبير جدا لكن
كمان فيه سيناريو اقل اللي هو وجود كيودو
مضايقات من جانب البحريه والحرس الثوري
الايراني على السفر ذهابا وايابا وارد
ايضا معنا هنا المضيق لم يغلق ولكنها تكون
فيه مضايقات
ما تكون في نسبه مخاطر عاليه اذا ارتفعت
نسبه المخاطر اللي بيتكلم على السيناريو
اقرب الى حرب الناقلات في الثمانينات اللي
حصل اثناء الثمانينات ان ال الملاحه لم
تتوقف في مضيق هرمز ولكن انخفضت بنسبه
خمسه وعشرين في المائه
وكانت النتيجه انه طبعا ارتفعت اسعار
النفط لاسباب مش بس انه قله المعروض ولكن
بسبب ارتفاع تكاليف في حاجه اسمه تامين
على شحن البترول تعريف شحن البروده في هذا
العام ارتفعت بنسبه مائه في المائه
وبالتالي ارتفعت اسعار البترول في العالم
كله تضرر منها العالم كله سواء كان
السيناريو الكبير جدا اللي هو اغلاق
المضيق او السيناريو الاصغر الاثنين
محفوفه بالمخاطر لايران وبيكون خط وصعب
انها تقوم العاليه وبالتالي
تقريبا كل ما بتسال محلل سواء في قطاع
النفط او عسكري او اقتصادي هل يمكن ان
تقبل ايران يتكلم وانتهى الثقه ان هذا لا
يمكن ان يحدث صعب جدا انه يحدث وعاده يعول
في تحليله او الجهاز نتكلم بالثقه اعتمادا
على انه تاريخيا لم يتم ابدا اغلاق مضيق
هرمز
لكن المواد اللي ما حدث انتبه اليها هو
انه زي ما بيقول الدكتور النسيم طالب عالم
الاقتصاد الشهير انه احداث التاريخ المهمه
لا تكرر نفسها ابدا يعني التاريخ لا يكرر
نفسه في الاحداث المهمه
وانه اذا كانت ايران لم تنجح ابدا الى
اغلاق مضيق هرمز من قبل هذا صحيح لكنها قد
تلقى لانه لم يسبق ان هددت الولايات
المتحده او اي دوله اخرى بالحاق انا يصل
الى تصفيه صادراتها من النفط تماما
وبالتالي اصابه اقتصادها بالشلل التام ما
يعني ان احنا نكون متوقفين قدره ايران على
العمل الانتحاري باغلاق مضيق هرمس يتوقف
على نجاح الولايات المتحده في تنفيذ
تهديداتها بتصفيه صادرات ايران من النفط
الى وزير بدايه من واحد او بدايه من
الثاني من ماي المقبل اذا نجحت لن يكون من
المستبعد ان تقبل ايران على هذه الخطوه
الانتحاريه واذا فشلت يبقى احنا بنتكلم
على تهديدات ك وفاء من الكاذبين الايام
المقبله هي الا تحمل لنا ما يمكن ان يحدث
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
ام
[موسيقى]